holiday season is here but people are
pissed a new study from USA Today found
out that sixty percent of americans
report feeling angry or irritable which
is up from fifty percent when a similar
poll was done 2011 I really don't
understand this because every commercial
you see on TV is for antidepressants so
they're obviously not working uh you
know and there's all kinds of public
people that are in in this anger fit
constantly between Alec Baldwin and
Chris Brown and all you know all these
endless people screaming about
everything and you know people are
saying that the anger epidemic could be
because of the economy and people are
upset about work and money and all that
and just the political gridlock do you
think America is angrier than it used to
be America's spoiled um I do I think
America's spoiled I think America feels
a bit entitled I can speak for my
generation particularly um a lot of it
if there is a lot of entitlement and
that's where a lot of anger is for
coming from it's like no you need to
look at yourself and you to hold
yourself a little bit more personally
accountable and I think some of that
anger and I like I'll take this for
example I had a pretty rough day the
other day and in those moments that's
what you turned a gratitude and you
actually just turn it all the way around
and you'd be grateful for what you do
have and then you get a game plan and
strategy together but what we know is
Chris Brown's not angry because he
doesn't have money so you know that's
that I don't believe I've alligator also
drive job role in the other not broke by
the way out Alden who lost his job at
MSNBC this week he still makes 15
million dollars a year capital one so
he'll be okay you know I think people
have always been angry i mean you talk
to your parents and they always talk
about the negative people that were in
their life the problem is that they just
didn't have twitter back then tell you
on a daily basis how angry i am and
about every little situation or on TV or
24 hour news networks i mean when you
were angry back in the 80s you didn't
make the nightly news right now when
you're angry we've got four networks
with 24-hour news coverage and youtube
to make sure that you know who's angry i
think people are probably exactly the
way that they've always been we just
know about it alright what people always
say we're more violent than ever but
then it's like you know they're the
crusades i'm pretty sure people walking
with an axe just happen
show that that's not true yeah um so the
social media part I think is kind
interesting cuz yeah we can get caught
up in all the anger all the time and all
that but I think there is something very
comforting about social media to that if
something bad happens is there's a
shooting or something that or the
terrorist attack in Boston let's say
that we have some ability to share like
an experience yeah and to know your
neighbors coffee choice in the morning
you know things are really important to
know see their Instagram day yes I have
to immediately go and see what kind of
eggs you chose yeah well you know
another thing though the social media
does that I don't like is it encourages
a lot of people to do this stupid
comparing thing you know where maybe I
if I feel might wake up feeling okay
about your life and then I look at your
timeline or your newsfeed and now I'm
pissed you know and that's it's so silly
I hate that about it but that really to
me is like a Instagram thing cuz
everything looks so much better on
Instagram so you wake up and you go oh
my friend had a glass of wine last night
but that looks that way better than in
my mind as I press that little button
yeah I don't think I was talking about a
second ago like stop it you know let's
just really take a moment and really
like get this together why the
thanksgiving talking points work because
people want to just follow somebody yeah
so go bring in this full circle yeah
what about anger at the holidays then
how how do you deal with you know if you
get into a big debate do you just let it
go or do you really bring it home well
the problem is a lot of festivities are
fueled by alcohol and uh oh you're
really belly the problem it's a good
thing but no one I think people just
kind of had that stuff pent up and then
after you know by the time you get to
nighttime at the house it's just all
it's all fair game yeah I think house we
always talk politics always oh yeah i
mean my house to me and my mom we go
back and forth and that's that's our
thing fios media politics how much of
this just the general anger thing has to
do with politics because of all the
cable news stuff and it's why i'm trying
to do this show so that's not just
screaming at each other but if you look
at something like crossfire which i
think is the like prototypical example
of this thing I'm on the right I'm on
the left and that we live in this
constant battle so how much just general
angst is because people just hear
messages that are fighting with each
other all time I we never
stop and say actually most of what we're
doing here is and people buy into it
what's crazy to me is when I'm on any
other cable news show and and I actually
deviate from this strong left or strong
right and I get to a point of considered
like people don't know what to do with
it and it's like and people from the
outside of some of the sheep they're so
tied to these talking points themselves
and being fed them that they almost
resent or don't know how to react when
you deviate from that yeah I mean that
you're preaching to the choir